Can we assume that you won't be
making any definitive decisions
about your future after
the release of this AG report
regardless of what started it
and instead you're going to wait
until the impeachment inquiry is
done in the state assembly
and my second question is
whether or not you would support
an aging investigation
specifically into the alleged
nursing home cover up
as families in Foley Square
today are protesting demanding
the nursing homes is being
looked at by the Eastern
District that was a political
investigation started by Donald
Trump,
who politicized not just COVID
but then politicized nursing
homes and policies towards
nursing homes and wanted
to blame Democratic governors
like myself and Michigan and New
Jersey and Pennsylvania.
It was all our fault and then
had his political Department
of Justice started
an investigation and they were
a political Department
of Justice there was no doubt
about that so that's being done
by the Department of Justice
and I've already told New
Yorkers where I am I did nothing
wrong and period and I'm not
resigning and I'm doing my job
every day.